hey 42 here with the wide reach of the
Internet
we've all seen how fast a meme can
spread and then before you know it
they're gone again like a ghost in the
night but this also happened before the
Internet
to let us have a look at some crazy
crazes and fabulous fads that took the
world by storm now in the modern world
of consumerism we all buy plenty of
stuff that we don't need in fact that's
probably most of what we buy this means
that selling goes useless products has
become something of an art form and led
some people to wonder what won't people
pay for in 1975 Gary Dahl gave a pretty
convincing case that you really can sell
absolutely anything for just under $4 he
gave you a smooth rock one that you
could have just picked up off the beach
or a riverbank pet rocks were probably
the biggest craze of the year and
although it died out within about six
months it was enough time for Gary to
become a millionaire your rock came in a
little box with a bed of straw and a
32-page user guide explaining the
difficult task of feeding grooming and
training your new best friend he hit on
the idea when he heard his buddies
talking in a bar complaining about
having to take care of their pets all
that food and poop and walks and eating
your shoes and making your house heavier
than a barbershops
floor so what if you could avoid all
these irritating issues and have a
simple pet that loved you only the way
that inanimate granites
can move a rock is cleaner than a dog
quieter than a hamster probably
friendlier than a cat and at least as
intelligent as a goldfish it's a win-win
Gary suddenly died in 2050 but he wanted
everyone to share in his superior sales
powers in 2001 he wrote the famous
advertising for dummies who the dummies
were in this situation is not exactly
clear whether it's rocks or cats pets
are hugely popular and it seems like our
love of cute animals is unlimited but
true
Japan to take it a little too far
kigurumi are the animal costumes
performers that you see it many
promotional events sports shows and so
on but the cutest army in the world
burst onto the streets in the mid-2000s
seemed getting on with their daily lives
dressed in a range of cartoon onesies
Japan has been obsessed with cuteness
for a long time and their term kawaii
can refer to everything from clothing to
shows to behavior even food he doesn't
want a sandwich with an adorable face
right many trends have grown out of this
from the creepily named fashion of sweet
Lolita which consists of lacy bonnets
bows and umbrellas as well as whitening
makeup to things like Hello Kitty and
Bora koji a style of fake childlike
hundred
the most popular Kiko room an outfit was
probably the little yellow rodent
Pokemon Pikachu partly because of the
characters mass appeal but also because
the bright yellow color most a lot of
the mustard and tea stains that your
daily onesie wearing normally creates
the mighty power of cuteness could not
be contained to Japan for very long
soon students across the UK and America
were nursing their hangovers in furry
style it's hard to feel sorry for
yourself when you're a unicorn I think
that's been proven by science speaking
of science our next craze shows just how
quickly our understanding of something
can change in 1898 Marie Curie and her
husband Pierre discovered radium element
number 88 in the periodic table it's a
metal and has a half-life of between
three point five days and 1600 years
depending on which isotope you're
dealing with for those of you who aren't
quite sure let me quickly explain the
basics of what a half-life is if you
have an amount of a substance which is
radioactive then its atoms are not
completely stable so they sometimes
decay and send out particles of matter
alpha and beta or energy in the form of
gamma rays the half-life is a prediction
of how long it will take before half of
the atoms in your
that stuff have decayed it's really more
of a probability the crazy fingers if
you had a piece of radium the size of a
grain of sand with a half-life of 1600
years it would still be decaying at a
rate of around half a billion atoms per
second so back to the craze when it was
announced that radium could be used to
attack cancer cells
people went radium crazy and it became a
health fad they put it in lotions syrups
tablets and plenty of overstock it was
basically the kale of the early 20th
century unfortunately while scale is
just a simple leaf radium makes you sick
to your bones since it often causes
cancer there Marie Curie herself died of
the cancer to her bone marrow and it
took us a while to come around to the
dangers of handling the substance some
of Curie's possessions such as her old
cookbook are still dangerous enough now
that they have to be stored in
lead-lined boxes the French government
is still cleaning up traces of
radioactive waste from the radium craze
to this day we didn't realize the
problem soon enough and it was used
across Europe and America both in
medicine and also for its
glow-in-the-dark quality a famous court
case arose around the radium girls a
group of women who had been painting
watch faces with radium paint they would
lick the tips of their brushes and it
was a few years before they realized
that they were poisoning themselves
speaking of paint
when I say graffiti most people are
going to think of street art like Banksy
or jr. or maybe your picture some toilet
scribble written with a sharpie but for
as long as there have been board people
and walls we've had graffiti and one of
the most widely spread doodles is Kilroy
Was Here
it's difficult to pin down a real origin
for this especially because the quote
and the image come from different places
who got combined at some point during
World War two
probably due to all the soldiers hanging
out in killing time together the image
was seen as early as World War what
known to Australians as foo and to the
Brits as mister
chat he's ended up with plenty of other
names over the years though such as
Herbie Overby flywheel private snoops
the Jeep and Clem the British mr. Chad
would often appear with a slogan saying
what no T or what no sugar as a
complaint about rationing as for the
image it could have been taken from lots
of things one popular idea is that it
comes to Malecha chol circuits since the
Australian versions often had a plus and
minus symbol for eyes and resembled the
diagram for a sine wave or even the
Omega a symbol for electrical resistance
the phrase Kilroy Was here is American
though and is likely from a ship
inspector called James J Kilroy he would
sign the phrase on part of the ship to
show that he'd checked them since
production during world war ii was so
fast often parts would not get painted
over so Navy personnel would find his
phrase scrawled in the most unlikely
corners of the ship and this is maybe
how the legend was born it was so
popular in the 40s and the 50s that it
said to have been drawn on everything
from the Great Wall of China to the
Statue of Liberty and rumor has it even
the moon it's also popped up in plenty
of books with a nod from Isaac Asimov
Robert a Heinlein Thomas Pynchon and
even Bill Watterson in everyone's
favorite Calvin and Hobbes you're at a
party and what better way to get things
going
then with a dance it doesn't matter if
you've got no rhythm or you're not
wearing the right shoes because today's
dance just involves walking onto a stick
that's right it's the limbo the dance
that's broke a thousand hips
it has everything you'd want from a
dance terrible music or group poses
under high probability of horrific
injury the strange thing is this dance
originated in Trinidad and was
originally performed at wags nothing
says you will be missed like rubbing
your nipples against a flaming stick the
1957 film fire down below is where the
dancer julia edward introduced a limbo
to a wider audience and chubby Checker's
hit single limbo rock in 1962 helped to
popularize it
it's not as common at parties these days
it's hard to Limbo to electronic music I
guess but as a competitive sport it's
still going strong
the current world record holder is
shemekka Charles a local Trinidadian
who's keeping the tradition alive in
2010 she danced her way into the
Guinness world record book shimmy and
gone to a bar just 21.5 centimeters high
that's less than the height of the
Guinness record book itself she even
went all the way under a car limbo is
part of a long list of dance crazes
allowing drunk uncles and weddings all
over the world to look as ridiculous as
possible whilst trying to show up their
in-laws whilst most people can at least
attempt to dance our next craze was
popular because of its innate difficulty
the Rubik's Cube is a multi-coloured
puzzle guaranteed to make you feel as
dumb as a monkey holding a smartphone
invented in 1974 by Erno Rubik a
hungarian sculptor and professor of
architecture the cube is about 6 by 6
centimeters and has a 3d cross in the
middle with 26 plastic cubes attached
around it the aim is to arrange the cube
so that each side is all one color and
no you're not allowed to just peel off
the stickers over 350 million rubik's
cubes have been sold around the world
and it is the best-selling toy in
history it's notoriously difficult for
most of us since there are a staggering
43 quintillion different combinations
but for a few fast fingered brain boxes
it's a piece of cake and the wall speed
record stands at just 4.9 seconds by
fourteen-year-old Lukas Etta various
other forms of the Rubik's Cube have
appeared over the years with increasing
number of sizes and shapes from a simple
4 by 4 cube to a yachtie mix now a
yachtie minx is a regular dodecahedron
meaning it has 12 faces which are all
Pentagon's which are divided into 15 by
15 pieces
it needs 2943 parts to make it if you do
manage to solve it its opens up a much
more important puzzle which is what are
you doing with your life
our next craze was also a puzzle of
sorts
what the pieces were people in the late
50s phone booths stuffing became a
challenge that spread through colleges
across North America Britain and South
Africa and on the 20th of March 1959 a
world record was set when 25 South
African men managed to cram their way
into a phone box at the Durban YMCA and
this remains the record despite the many
different attempts made and a variety of
techniques that students dreamed up
whilst doing their best to avoid any
actual work a Canadian school managed to
get 40 in a booth but they had tipped it
on its side and used one that was
already larger than average so rules
were set regarding the size and the
position of the phone booth as well as
how much of a person needed to actually
be inside to count towards the total the
Brits took it one step further
since we're sticklers for doing things
properly you had to make or receive a
call in order to complete the attempt
yeah hi mum I'm just at a phone box with
39 other people I think I might be late
for dinner
if you want to try it for yourself then
the sooner the better for the mighty
phone booth is becoming extinct in the
US the peak number was 2.6 million in
1995 but that number has plummeted and
it's now well under 500,000 and dropping
every day with the prevalence of mobile
phones a phone booth is basically a tiny
smelly Museum with bad advertising and
some suspicious flyers if you are
thinking about making a call in Brazil
however and leafing your way through the
phone book to look up a number you might
start to notice a rather wonderful
Brazilian craze that is still going on
to this day giving your children crazy
names in some countries such as Denmark
there are very strict laws around naming
a newborn there is a list of approved
names and the name must correctly
indicate the gender of the child in
Brazil it's practically a competition to
see who can come up with the longest
obscurus names referencing everything
from historical figures for example
Francisco Lyndon Johnson Menezes died
jr. also numbers such as deset Rosado
or office equipment even like Xerox
Porfirio so what's the reason for all of
this well it's hard to say exactly no
doubt the rich history of immigration
and colonialism had a big impact on
their naming culture also there's been a
feeling of higher class attached to some
countries outside of Brazil by its
residence such as the US for example
so therefore names associated with these
countries probably hope to adopt part of
their perceived glamour although I'm not
quite sure a lot Jose Roberto would
agree this football is first name is
supposed to be Hollywood but the
Brazilian ization has lost a little
something along the way he's not the
only comically named player Eva he's
beaten by Creedence Clearwater cuto so
what a Brazilian folk Tyrel being
referred to is mounted on Lima de Moura
or Oceano Atlanta Colin Harris well you
can legally change it but the court
system is very slow and difficult and
many people just choose not to bother
embracing their parents decision and
buying an extra-wide ID card
our final fad is one close to my heart
because I played it on many a sunny
afternoon back when I was a kid it is a
ferociously competitive game called
conquers conquers are horse-chestnut so
known as Buckeyes in North America and
they usually start falling from the tall
trees in their green spiky shells around
the middle of September unlike their
brothers the sweet chestnut which have a
much spiky ashell and pointed seed they
are not edible in fact they are very
mildly poisonous but since they are
found lying around outside school yards
the kids were smart enough to put them
to good use the aim of conkers is to
smash your opponent's conker you drill a
small hole through the middle of the
conker and then attacks a string you
then take it in turns to strike the
other person's conker until one of the
conquerors cracks it's basically British
Pokemon with conkers instead of
pokeballs and keep furry animals there
was actually a classic n64 game called
Conker's Bad Fur Day but it was a
platformer about
- dirty mouth squirrel rather than a
very neat conquer battle simulator
typing Bovril bullets hole in the cheat
menu here would give you 50 lives but
cheating in actual conquers required a
lot more effort some of the more popular
methods for cheating were boiling them
in vinegar and then baking them or
painting them with nail polish but if
you really want to be king of the
playground world conquer champion
Charlie Bray claims that the best is to
pass it through a pig the conker will
harden by soaking in its stomach juices
then you search through the pigs waist
to find the conga hey sometimes you've
got to get your hands dirty if you want
to be a real winner we roll arise it
every stupid new fad that comes along
sometimes but we all know deep down that
we've been a part of something just as
ridiculous before and probably will be
again that's what makes life interesting
right thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42
you